direct avec claudia nasa pillon médecin
généraliste à munich en allemagne
bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france est-ce que selon vous l'allemagne
est prête pour ce déconfinement
aujourd'hui apparemment oui on a on est
très bien formés les chansons tranquille
on accepte les contraintes des la porter
les masques la distance dans les
magasins mais la peau retournée pas
c'est très très léchée c'est très très
doucement ça ce n'est pas tout de suite
la vie d'avant quels sont vos retours
sur le quel sont vos retours du terrain
que vous disent vos patients est ce
qu'ils sont inquiets ceux des
confinement qui commence donc
aujourd'hui est-ce qu'ils jouent le jeu
qu'est ce qu'on vous dit nos les
chansons qu'ils sont bien informés et
n'ont pas peur et ils prennent tous
assez de précautions on a eu un
confinement plus l'échec ailleurs en
tant que l'on pouvait sortir tout seul
faire du sport une promener les enfants
des choses qui font à la vie de tous les
jours qui après saint peu les
contraintes et pas pouvoir aller à tous
les magasins ne pas pouvoir tous aller à
son travail de travail est souvent à la
maison d'avoir les enfants à la maison
avec le treuil de l'école est évidemment
c'est très contraignant mais les champs
pu faire au moins des promenades au
moins des promeneurs vélo avec les
enfants sur tout et pour tous les âges
évidemment le contact social c'est un
problème mais au moins pouvoir se
dépenser physiquement ça a été sans
doute
une aide à supporter les changements qui
sont encore très très très tués et
blessés stricte et alors comment est ce
que vous expliquer ces différences
majeures entre la france et l'allemagne
près de 4000 morts outre-rhin plus de
19000 700 dans l'hexagone le confinement
s'est pourtant fait mi mars dans les
deux pays est ce que c'est simplement
aussi une question de tests de dépistage
non non évidemment la capacité des
dépisteurs est ici très bien préparé
mais aussi s'est très bien préparé
toutes les dispositions de basse
beaucoup des cliniques au coude et
clinique orthopédique beaucoup de
cliniques de réanimation qui mettait
tout de suite bloqués en attendant des
patients qu'aux vide mais il ya eu le
système de santé
c'est sans doute la différence entre les
autres pays qui sont des résultats -
moins joyeux et vous voyez la gestion de
cette crise sanitaire
ici chez nous en france quel est votre
regard de médecin je peux pas changer
les détails
d'ailleurs je peux vous dire simplement
comment ça se passe ici et ici il ya eu
encore une très large place d'emile tine
est très bien connecté
c'est aussi une grande aide pour des
moments comme ça où tout les données
sont bien cordiner des basses et pour
réagir d'insuline
et situation exceptionnelle historiques
comme celle là et ça ça me doute payé un
résultat dans l'eau assez rapidement
hier le premier ministre français a
annoncé que le port du masque pourrait
devenir obligatoire à partir du 11 mai
prochain ici dans les transports publics
est ce que selon vous ce port du masque
in nécessité ça va être ici aussi à
partir la semaine prochaine dans les
espaces publics le transport et marin et
mais c'est pas forcément ni masque
médical ça peut être aussi un châle qui
couvrent la bouche le nez
et effectivement ça va à éviter le
contact réduire le contact s'est pas
c'est pas à 100% mais ça va aller chez
la rue
la police de vie normale merci beaucoup
d'avoir pris le temps de répondre à nos
questions claudia happillon je rappelle
que vous êtes médecin à munich en
allemagne